en las imágenes de las cámaras de
seguridad de la estación del Instituto
Nacional de Migración en Ciudad Juárez
se ve el momento en el que inicia el
incendio en el que murieron 38 migrantes
y a unos guardias de seguridad que pasan
frente a la cámara y parecen salir del
recinto al menos hasta ese momento no
abren las puertas de las celdas donde
estaban los detenidos el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador quien había
responsabilizado del incidente a los
migrantes en el centro por según él
oponerse a ser deportados y un giro a
sus declaraciones y dijo que
investigaría los hechos debido a las
nuevas versiones que han salido a la luz
se están haciendo
todas las investigaciones para
conocer lo que realmente
sucedió una información preliminar pero
queremos tener
todos los elementos para informar
si es posible hoy mismo
informar sobre lo que sucedió
en
la versión de
el gobierno que represento
al frente del centro donde ocurrió la
conflagración un grupo de migrantes
protestaba por la falta de información y
por el trato que han recibido
a toda esa persona que estuvieron ahí
que fallecieron les pudieron abrir la
reja porque de la reja a donde se para
los agentes de migración son
ni metros hay un tremendo hermetismo hay
mucho silencio nadie dice nada el
Gobierno Federal ni migración ni el
gobierno del Estado ni el gobierno
municipal en medio de la oleada
migratoria que enfrenta a México el
embajador de Estados Unidos en este país
que en Salazar dijo que la tragedia era
un recordatorio para los gobiernos de la
región de la importancia de arreglar un
sistema migratorio que no funciona y los
riesgos de la migración irregular